the u.s has a long way to go on vaccine
distribution but
we are way ahead of most other countries
that includes germany
where many are choosing to wait for one
vaccine over another
instead of just getting the shot that is
most available
chris livesay is in hamburg with more on
that story chris what is going on there
well good morning gail now the u.s has
60 million doses
of the astrazeneca vaccine ready to roll
out as soon as the fda approves it now
here in germany where cases of the
disease have been rising
they already have astrazeneca the only
hard part
is getting germans to take it at
germany's biggest vaccination center in
hamburg
35 year old surgeon johannes was eager
to finally get his shot
and begin to rest easy with his partner
and newborn son
but now i'm a little bit afraid
i get the astra zenica vaccine
i thought that i was getting the
biontech vaccine but now here i heard
that
there's the decision that i don't get it
i was really disappointed
it's a scene playing out across europe's
most powerful country
so far germany has received more than
1.4 million doses of astrazeneca
in vaccination centers like these the
problem well half of germans say
they don't really want it the european
union has secured a whopping 400 million
doses
but then germany's vaccine committee
refused to approve
astrazeneca for those over 65 citing a
lack of data
instead they'll get the pfizer shot the
backlash was spawned
so if somebody calls you right now and
says we have the astrazeneca vaccine for
you
what would you say i would say no thanks
uh give it to people who really need it
yeah
kind of vaccine that's despite new
real-world data from the united kingdom
that showed the astrazeneca vaccine was
more effective than the pfizer shot in
preventing hospitalization
a stunning breakthrough says
immunologist thomas jacobs
we have not the best and the second best
i think we have two very effective
and safe vaccines do you think that
people are being snobs when it comes to
the vaccine
yeah maybe a little bit and with many
germans turning their noses up at
astrazeneca
most sits in cold storage compared to
more than 15 percent of americans
getting their first shot
less than 6 percent of germans have
gotten theirs
though that number is growing we all
want to
get back into normal life yes
now that perception might be changing
german chancellor angela merkel
has defended the astrazeneca vaccine and
she's meeting today with leaders to
decide the next
phase of the pandemic response this in a
country
that's still largely locked down tony
all right chris livesay in germany for
us chris thank you very much